you know that M3 chip from Apple that's
apparently supposed to come at WWDC in
June well no it looks like that's not
happening Mark German just came out with
a massive bombshell leak that completely
flips the script on other leaks but
there's also the little chance that the
M3 chip might not turn out as exciting
as we thought according to an
interesting idea from nine to five Mac
so let's get started here's the big
headline from Mark German the 15-inch
MacBook Air with an M2 like chip has
been spotted in developer locks now yes
he's saying that the M2 Chip is more
likely than the M3 in terms of which one
the 15-inch MacBook Air is getting now I
know that sounds like terrible news but
it means that the 15-inch model could be
released sooner than later as soon as
WWDC or maybe even earlier and then on
top of that he also gave us a ton of
other info detailing the 15-inch MacBook
Air in his actual Bloomberg article so
let's run through the whole thing as you
can see right here the next Generation
MacBook Air with a larger screen is in
the works and the new machine is on par
with M2 Max with M3 chips coming later
so that's a very interesting detail the
chip and the new 15-inch laptop has
eight main processing cores and 10
Graphics cores just like the current M2
including eight gigs of memory in line
with the existing MacBook Air which
makes it seem like it's gonna be the
actual M2 Chip now the main CPU is still
going to be split into four high
performance cores and four efficiency
but the interesting thing is that the
Mac is testing using Mac OS 14 which is
the future version that apple is going
to show off at
WWDC now as far as the screen resolution
for this laptop it's going to be
codenamed the Mac 15 comma 3 and it's
going to be equal to the 14 inch
high-end MacBook Pro and that means that
the 15 inch larger air would have the
same resolution as the 14 inch pro but
with slightly less sharpness or lower
pixels per inch so that is very
interesting that they're doing that and
here's the kicker he says that bigger
changes to the Mac will be coming later
with the release of an M3 chip which
will represent a transition to a three
nanometer production process from the
current five nanometer standard and
that's going to give you improved
performance and efficiency which I've
talked about before now this point right
here is very interesting specifically
his wording beyond the larger MacBook
Air the company is working on an update
to the 13-inch Air Model the 24 inch
iMac and the entry level 13 inch MacBook
Pro which basically makes it seem like
he's not expecting those products until
later in the year which I think it makes
sense to launch with an M3 chip in
either October or November and I've been
saying that for quite a while now and
basically every single video that I've
made and he also gave some interesting
points about the Mac Pro which could be
facing some delays in the future 14 and
16 inch MacBook Pros in the first half
of 2024 with the higher end versions of
the M3 now we did say that the 15-ish
model in question was running Mac OS 14
but I don't believe that it means that
it must come at WWDC why well because
Mac OS 14 isn't going to be fully
released until the fall anyway so what
if this software is irrelevant to the
launch and it could still come with Mac
OS 13 but now let's get into the leaks
from other leakers that solidify exactly
what Mark German is saying and this is
actually very interesting because there
were some conflicting rumors with Ross
young at the head of them now Ross Young
Who is a display consultant basically
the best apple leaker in terms of
display leaks he's got countless of them
correct he is saying that production of
the 15-inch MacBook Air components is
underway in a WWDC launch is looking
likely and he even said it could happen
late April or early may even that soon
we could be seeing the 15-inch MacBook
Air launch now that is on top of
previous rumors that he did in February
when he said that the 15-ish MacBook
gear would launch in April as display
production has began so what if later
this month we might even see an M2
15-inch MacBook Air and even before then
in March he did say it's on track to
launch in April and finally a different
Source completely different digit time
said that the 15-inch MacBook Air would
reportedly have an M2 Chip so all of it
is coming to together and it all makes
sense because if it does have an M2 Chip
it can come as early as April but it if
it has an M3 it's got to be later at
least WWDC in my opinion the fall of
this year and finally we had an earlier
leak from Mark German back in March
saying that Apple was readying its next
range of Max including finally a new
iMac that would come at least later this
year maybe the spring of next year but
he said that apple is going to be
launching about three new maps between
late spring and summer those three
models being the 15-inch air the first
Mac Pro and an update to the 13-inch
MacBook Air and then he also said that
both a 13 and 15 inch are likely however
he said that the chips on those models
would be a big remaining question
because he wasn't exactly sure but in
the new reports that he just did today
he did imply that the 13 inch MacBook
here with the M3 chip is gonna be coming
later alongside other M3 Max and he also
said that the Mac Pro is facing new
delays which could mean that it might
not even show up at WWDC or maybe it'll
just be a reveal with a further launch
date later this year but what it means
is that he expects the 15-inch MacBook
Air to come first that's for sure and
maybe even by itself probably pointing
to a WWDC launch or maybe even sooner
now the final question is this why would
Apple release the 15-inch first with an
M2 Chip instead of waiting for the M3
chip so they can launch it alongside the
13-inch model well I think it could be a
business trick or a plan where they know
that people are waiting for some new
MacBooks because of all the rumors
especially with the hype surrounding a
15 inch model which so many people are
waiting on so they can release the 15
inch first make some profit on all of
the orders and then later they can come
out with a banger M3 13-inch MacBook Air
to get another big wave of orders but
the biggest thing you need to understand
is that if the 15 inch comes with an M2
Chip it's not going to be upgraded to an
M3 later this year alongside the 13 inch
and this actually makes sense for Apple
to do because if they offer both a 15
inch display and an M3 chip in a MacBook
Air who in the world would buy the base
14 inch MacBook Pro with the M2 Pro chip
nobody especially since I made a video
predicting the performance of the M3
chip and it's actually faster than the
bend M2 Pro in the base 14 inch MacBook
Pro now the only other option that would
be even worse is the possibility that
Apple might bifurcate the M3 chip family
according to 95 Mac which means making
the regular M3 chip be based on Apple's
a16 ship which is basic five nanometer
while the rest of the M3 chip family
like the M3 Pro Max and Ultra will be
based on three nanometer next year that
would basically mean that Apple would
release both the 13 and 15 inch MacBook
airs at WWDC with an M3 chip but it
won't be three nanometer which means it
would suck and it would basically be
another stop Gap chip product but for
Apple it would solve the issue of the M3
being faster than the M2 Pro and the
reason 95 Mac is saying that is because
they had an exclusive leak back in March
saying that both a 13 and 15 inch
MacBook Air models will both use M3
chips so if they're correct either one
of two things is happening either both
the 13 and 15 inch are getting delayed
until the fall or the 15 inch will come
first with an M3 chip and if they're
correct then that means that both the 15
and 13 inch can come at the same time as
early as WWDC with a three nanometer
chip built on five nanometer which would
definitely suck but Apple would be
stalling even longer with the stop Gap
chips until finally giving us three
nanometer next year with the higher end
models and that way there's no
cannibalizing going on at all so you
guys let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below click the
circle button subscribe for more videos
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
foreign